the jurogan experience while i was
playing music actually i i turned the
studio certain nights a week into a
little poker room so i'd have like
friends over and we'd play cards the
house
but uh
while i was uh
touring
uh i eventually decided because when i
when i decided to stop going to school i
said to myself if the music doesn't work
i'm gonna go to sushi school
so uh the music thing did work
and a couple years went by and
um actually my godmother owned a uh
catering company
and so
uh in between tours i didn't really want
to keep working at like jambo juice or
starbucks or anything like that
and so i uh asked her if i could work
for her and so i invited over her her
over to the house i cooked dinner for
her and she said well i'll introduce you
to my chef and if my chef wants to hire
you then you'll be hired
and so i went to uh to her um catering
company met the chef
uh
the first thing was like okay you're
making family meal today and so i cooked
for the whole staff and she said
i'll hire you as a dishwasher
oh jesus uh and was that because that
was the only job they had available
looking back at it i was offended and
angry but i didn't care because of what
she said after that which is um you
don't get to start being a cook you have
to start
as a dishwasher so you can have respect
for
um you know what it is that the
dishwashers do
and
she said here's how this works the
faster you clean that dish pit
the more i'll teach you so whenever that
dish pits clean you come and find me and
i'll give you a task but if there's ever
any dishes
that's what you're doing
so it kind of gave me that that bit of
work ethic of like all right i'm gonna
work my way into that that next position
that seems to be a theme with great
restaurants and when you talk to chefs
this work ethic theme because it seems
like
when you know you talk to people that
have worked in restaurants one of the
things that they will almost unanimously
discuss is the amount of hours and the
grind and how difficult it is yeah and
that development of work ethic almost is
like kind of a boot camp
for chefs
it is it's um
i mean
it's not so much
anymore laws have changed culture has
changed
but it was
you're spending like a 16-hour day was
not
even a really long day
i dated a girl once who went to
college for restaurant and hotel
management and then she got a job at
this restaurant and i remember i would
go visit her and she was
[ __ ]
miserable
i mean miserable she couldn't believe
the hours that she had to work but you
have to love it yes that's an industry
you have to love well she just wanted a
career you know she'd went to school she
graduated from school and then she had
this this job that was like and then she
had this boyfriend who was a fuck-up
who's a comedian so it was like very
very weird for her because like i had
most of my day completely free
and she was working you know 14 15 hours
a day at least yeah i mean it's it's one
of those things where
if you really want to take food
seriously and cooking seriously you're
going to have to
you know make a lot of sacrifices yeah
you know just the time mm-hmm you're not
there for birthdays you're not there for
anniversaries you're not there for for
for uh valentine's day for sure
because you have to work because you
have to work yeah yeah because someone
has to cook at all those restaurants you
go to yeah
yeah people listening
if you are thinking of going down this
path
yeah it's a fantastic path but you have
to understand
what it's like and i think the reason it
worked for me or the reason i loved it
so much is it really felt like being on
tour
except i got to sleep in my own bed
well be like playing music you spend all
day getting ready for the show that
night
um
and there's something to getting to the
restaurant and prepping all day getting
ready for the show that night
um and so i feel like
the camaraderie of being on it like
being in a crew is much is a lot like
being in a band um the hours are a lot
like being in a band um
and then the shenanigans you know after
hours are a lot like being in a band the
boozing yeah you're talking about yeah
that's the other thing that i learned
from bourdain i didn't know how hard
people partied
yeah i mean when i was younger there was
a lot of nights you just
don't go to sleep you just get out of
the restaurant at 1 30 in the morning
you go to the bar then you go somewhere
else then you
go back and open the restaurant the next
day
that doesn't seem good for you no it's
terrible i had i had to um
and that's where the red bull comes in
well no i quit red bull earlier than
that but um uh thankfully i never i
never gotten a drug so it wasn't that
but i would drink a lot and i actually
had one time uh
where i
finished service took two steps and just
collapsed just hit the ground whoa yeah
at the end of the day at the end of the
day it was pulled an all-nighter i think
two or three days in a row yeah oh jesus
but i was like 21.
two or three days of no sleep at 21 yeah
maybe like an hour and a half sleep here
and there jesus
but um yeah i mean when i i my first
sous chef job i was on the schedule it
said
next to my name all seven days said
op-ciel
open to close
we did breakfast
and we did dinner service so i would
open the restaurant at about 7 a.m and i
would leave around 1 32. so when you
open the restaurant at 7am what time are
you actually arriving
uh man this was
like this a long time ago but i'm i
probably was getting there
i was probably getting there on seven 6
45 7. when i say open i mean i would get
to the restaurant open the door not that
we were
so there was someone there that was
already prepping
yeah i'm trying to remember because we
were at this um
in this sort of like uh the restaurant
was a lunch and dinner restaurant but we
served
breakfast and as like a commissary to
like there was like it was like in a
building complex
um so i really wasn't responsible for
breakfast um so there would be i think
there was people there before i would
get there building like an office
building complex yeah so they would just
grab something quick yeah
yeah like so i would get in there and
the dishwasher would already like he'd
be making like ham and cheese sandwiches
or something like that
but um and so you were there from seven
a.m and then what time would you get out
of there
usually
i mean
i probably won 130. and
nowadays with labor laws you really
couldn't schedule that right well i was
on i was on salary
oh interesting but that salary would
have to be you know 3x at this point
yeah because because now they've changed
the rule a couple years ago
salary is no longer a
uh a contract between you and i salaries
have to fall into a certain you have to
qualify
so you can't just be like oh i'm gonna
not give you overtime by giving you a
salary to have you work when i ask you
to right now you have to pay them pay
everybody a specific dollar amount and
they have to have hold specific
responsibilities in order to not uh
accrue over time
yeah i think that's good because i think
there's a lot of employers that are
abusive
but i also think there's something
romantic about this story of you almost
dying
[Laughter]
you know what i mean i feel like i do
appreciate like long hard work days
there's something to that because like i
hear that and i know you got through it
you became very successful so i'm like
see it works look when i think margarita
in my first date was at that restaurant
and it was uh
i mean people ask me all the time how
did how did you get her
and it's food it has to be
that's hilarious um well you're a cool
guy don't tell yourself short and plus
you're kind of cute appreciate it jeremy
i'm top three in this room for sure
um top three
i would say so um
but uh so because of that schedule i
couldn't take her on a date
um and so i remember
the very first date we had was at the
restaurant i told her to show up at 12
30 after i sent everybody home
and i had spent all day secretly
prepping a special menu and she showed
up
and i sat her in the dining room that
like overlooked the kitchen and i would
make a course bring it out to her sit
down with her have a sip of wine
and then uh uh go back in the kitchen
make the next course oh wow yeah what
did you think she did during the time
when you were in there cooking uh well i
told her to bring a friend with her
because i told her that i'm gonna you
know otherwise she's there for 20
minutes in between each course
that's that well listen man that's a
clever move look it worked yeah clearly
yeah
that's a that's interesting i mean i
would imagine that that's probably one
of the most difficult occupations to
date in yeah
um i i sacrificed a lot of um
uh
relationships
prior to that one yeah i can only
imagine